the basic construct is the best of
America in a taco you won't find a
drive-through at yum brands newest taco
restaurant and you won't find ground
beef burrito shells or paper wrappers
either the middle one is called the
southern Squealer inside pulled pork
taco so on the bottom there's a sweet
corn cake and then we cover that with
the pulled pork and we put a peach
jalapeno barbecue sauce on that the menu
at us taco company features 10 tacos
with whimsical names nodding to classic
American regional ingredients the hot
chick is a twist on buffalo wings the
one percenter that's a Maine lobster
roll not my first rodeo features Texas
brisket want to get laid serves a Hawaii
style mahi-mahi us tackle company's
first restaurant opens in August in
Huntington Beach California the 2,000
square foot beach shack matches up a day
of the dead theme with a red white and
blue color palette we've tried to create
a food truck that you don't have to
chase the look and feel is very
important to the experience because us
taco is really about a dining experience
and just as important to the food is the
environment once you enjoy it you won't
find booze at the huntington beach shop
attack them is plan for future locations
with edgy offerings like the ice cream
and Guinness base Mexican car bomb
this is not the first push into the 34
billion dollar fast-casual market for
Taco Bell's parent company yum has
opened a higher-end KFC location in
Louisville dubbed KFC eleven and a new
sandwich restaurant in Arlington Texas
called super chicks it hopes us taco
company will take Taco Bell success in
quick service to another level there was
this other large demographic the folks
that love Mexican food but aren't
necessarily fast food users it is a
fast-growing place in the category and
we thought we could present a really
unique concept that had a different
version of what else is going on the
market